the Joe Rogan experience how far away do
you think we are from artificial general
intelligence so by nature I'm an
optimist I am you know I tend to I to
underestimate how long things take but
on the other hand as a programmer I've
usually been able to say well maybe I
missed my estimate by 50% while
everybody else blew it by a hundred
percent or something I think that we
will have we will potentially have
unclear signs of AGI maybe as soon as a
decade from now
Wow now lots of people disagree the
majority of scientists working on it
think it's like oh it's gonna be at
least a few decades and you still have a
few holdouts that say oh it can't happen
at all but I'm a strict materialist I
think that you know our minds are just
our body in action and there's no reason
why we can't wind up simulating that in
some way I am so I don't think the
question of how far off there's a lot of
numbers that you can play like the the
brain has something like 85 billion
neurons in it in the room they have
something like 10,000 connections
between it and you can multiply those
out and compare them to what we have in
computer memory and processing time and
you can say that
yeah within 10 years those curves should
have crossed but I would even go so far
as to say most of those are probably not
completely necessary we know lots of
biological systems like we understand
the processing that goes on a lot in the
visual side and we don't need nearly as
many computer transistors as neurons
that are used for processing some of
those early layers so I suspect that
even today some of the government
supercomputers that the biggest the top
500 list that they have those are
remarkably I probably useful for doing
Intel it artificial intelligence work
where for a long time for decades I
thought that was sort of just I am
national chest-thumping the top 500
computers because so many of them they
relied on replacing what used to be the
old big iron Cray vector supercomputers
and they really weren't very easy to
program most programs people want to use
you can't run it on a supercomputer and
just be a lot faster one of the shocking
things most people don't really
appreciate is the fastest way to do most
single threaded applications is an
overclocked gaming computer today you
can
go spend a million dollars and buy a
computer that will do many tasks faster
than what you can just run on a gaming
computer and this is not at all the way
things were for decades where for a long
time
you would go spend your millions of
dollars on a Cray supercomputer and all
of your code would run faster than
anything you can get but it turned out
that the the processors that you wind up
using in high-end gaming systems are in
many cases the fastest or in all cases
at least close to as fast for certain
serial applications so the only thing
else you can do is pile lots more of
them together and these big computers
are football field-sized AI systems
they're just racks and racks of GPUs and
CPUs and nowadays for a long time I'd be
like well what would you I would think
how could I make a faster quake map
build or something on one of those
because we would sometimes have hours
and hours spent processing this and I at
one point we had a computer that was
almost in the top 500 I'm at it software
just for making our Maps
I but I looked at a lot of these
supercomputers and like how these are
terrible not very useful for what we
want i but now as I look at AI work and
I think that well if you're just doing a
whole bunch of these I kind of general
matrix multiplies that computer right
there it's probably pretty good so I
would suspect that you could do
something if we had the right algorithms
the right training schedule and the
right time to run through it that it's
probably possible on some systems today
and it'll just still take many years for
the right algorithms to wind up being
developed the right training regimens to
be run and faster cheaper hardware and
why did it make it more economical to
run all the experiments because in so
many cases the trick is not that the
minimum requirements exists but that a
thousand people have thrown themselves
at the wall of a problem
most of the bounced off and failed but
eventually somebody gets through now
what about quantum computing is that
something that could potentially break
the bottleneck that we have with Moore's
Law so I don't I am NOT an expert on
quantum computing and I I think that is
many times I beat myself up about it
where there's some simulators online
where you can go and work on it and I
should work through the exercises of
doing the basic factoring algorithms on
quantum computing but I know my read on
it right now is that it's probably
directly useful for most of the
artificial intelligence tasks the big
things that people worry about that are
for things like breaking cryptography
breaking the different hashes and
encryption methods that it's possible
that in many ways that's almost a
terrible technology because it's a
technology that doesn't solve so many of
the problems that you'd like it to solve
and it does solve one of the problems
you kind of wish nobody was able to
solve I am so I fight breaking all the
encryption you know like if somebody
winds up I with a quantum computer that
they achieve quantum supremacy and it
runs past all of our traditional
computers and all of a sudden they can
break all of the all of the secure
socket layer stuff break everybody's
signatures impersonate any public key
sign stuff there's no upside to this
that's all downside and all bad things
they're gonna come from that while it's
not gonna make your video encoding go
any faster and it's probably not going
to help artificial intelligence in many
ways so I haven't found a whole lot to
get me really excited about quantum I am
computing it may just be that yeah and
with all these cases why I beat myself
up about not learning more about it
because in most cases when presented
with some capability there's some way to
figure out how to apply it usefully to
the things that you really want in fact
I consider that almost the essence of
engineering engineering is figuring out
how to do what you want with what you've
actually got and if somebody gives
anytime somebody gives me new hardware
usually I can figure out some useful way
to do things that I want with it even if
it's not immediately obvious and maybe
quantum computing plays out that way but
I am it is still definitely the domain
of big labs with cryogenic cooling and
all that stuff so hmm it just hasn't
been at the top of my radar